hi so guys welcome back for those of you
who stuck around well yeah
please let me know if you can hear me
and everything is okay because I wasn't
the word that's we have started so yeah
thank you for those of you who already
suggested a move
so yeah just okay great
I'm live and they don't know it perfect
alright so this one is a game between
[Music]
sheriff and aleksandr mafia they're both
super grandmasters 26 plus and so yeah
yep for those of you who suggest the
turkish seven you were correct
mainly because if take this is mates and
so i'm gonna take a second to go back
and show you how we got to this position
so we got to this position because in
the game black bites queenie eight
turkish one was the nice move which is
kind of already preparing for the attack
tank we have six and this Bishop d7
because if you weren't if you were not
fine to play Bishop d7 you still have a
very pleasant position but the problem
is that black is kind of covering it up
so it's after Bishop d7 you get the
chance to play this beautiful wreckage
seven so thank you for those of you who
told me as alright
one
this one is also white to move blacks
flatspin was bringing the Queen to f8
okay yes Queen d7 is the correct move
whoa
yep and the point is after queen h7 if
like thanks you have this double check
and then mate so thank you for that so
the question is how should white use the
power of his active pieces so please
think about that question and tell me
what would you want to do because you
can see why specific t'v so there should
be something there
oh sorry
okay so I have a suggestion of Bishop f5
so far let's see what else do you have
well don't just give me one liner tell
me like Bishop a5 what do you think
white should do what do you think black
should do and so on okay so you think
black the background is super weak and
you want to use that
all right so let's see
yep you are right the background is
super weak so the idea is instead of
Bishop takes a five queen takes a five
is the importance move so after Queen at
five the problem is Queen takes a five
Bishop takes and black loses the Knights
so if we're if black were to give Queen
g6 check so please tell me what would
you do after Queen g6 check and
[Music]
so after the check just think about you
logically only have two moves so just
make sure you think about both of those
modes and decide which one is better but
I think either one at this position you
are kind of winning regardless of which
one wish moved to play so okay I'm gonna
show you for example if you take win g6
taken I teach for this is winning the
other one which is more efficient is
King f1 and the idea is if you take this
well mate and if you take with Queen and
just take back with the bishop and you
can't you just can't hold everything
together because c8 is happening Queen
f8 is happening Queen just Queen C it is
happening there's a lot of thing that's
happening and you just can't keep it all
in check so
next one is black to move and the
question is blacks positional advantage
is kind of overwhelming but how can you
convert it into a full points
okay so I'm getting suggestions of Queen
age too but maybe give me full lines to
acquiesce to what if the black
what if cleaners to Queen takes package
to
it's good that you're thinking about
checks and tanks but be sure to care be
very careful of what your opponent has
to do to
okay so I'm getting Bishop D for Miss of
h2 personally I kind of liked idea
Bishop h2 so let's see what they played
fish of h2 so the idea is if you take I
give you check and you have to play King
G 1 so now you get this nasty Queen III
and the problem is after taking Queen e2
and then you lose the rook and most
likely the gamecaster of tea tree is
coming and this is just your king is
super super weak so this one is white to
move and the question is white needs
extra power because the attack to
complete the attack so how can you fill
it up
make sure to keep thinking about checks
and takes and just beware be aware of
your position basically so g5 is a very
nice idea I like it just make sure you
calculate everything because rocketry
could be happening
or maybe g5 maybe there's like a queen a
six if it works well that's the question
do you think it works
okay so everybody well a lot of people
are going for g5 which I think it is
correct I was trying to throw you off a
little bit because g5 if you were to
play Queenie six there is this queen of
six chick I think take take and you win
the rook and for example if no Queen if
for example raucous tree you sample you
have queen of six and just take back in
your trading mates and yeah
even if the King tries to run away you
still have this powerful c4 because now
if regardless of where the Queen goes
you are going to win either take the
rook or mate let's look at one final
Queen b7 and even in this you will have
to just take on d6 in your threatening a
rookie to eat meat so
this one is black and basically how can
black keep keep this game and try to get
something out of it so fun fact this
game was played in 2002 by one and only
yasser cr1 he was black so yeah what do
you think yes or did
okay so we are getting at questions and
suggestions on Queenie for let's see
preferably give me like a few moves
suggestion like if Queenie for like well
we can see that white can't take but
even when one white can't take well what
can whites do something like that or if
there's nothing for what to do just be
like yep there's nothing for white to do
so yep Queenie for is the right idea
because if you take you just get mated
and if you don't take your Queen just
simply doesn't have anywhere to go
let's say Queen of three you just take
it and the Queen can't just keep
protecting the rook
so yeah for this one you don't they
didn't really need to give me a full
line because it was kind of
self-explanatory but yeah so ideally
give me lines moving forward alright so
this one the question is why it has
gathered many pieces around the enemy
king how can he conclude this attack now
so it is why Shamu and basically how can
you win
okay I'm getting a lot of good
suggestions over g7 Jack and for example
rugby one again preferably give me a
line like if for example if route me 100
teaching what should do I black should
do
okay so we have the twin will be 100
Keisha
so rupee one is better because you can
you need this you can need to distract
the Queen away and after queen bee one
you get
taketake and then them to the mate and
for example if black tries to give you a
check you just have King G 2 whereas if
you were to take over here first then
drug g7 and I don't really see a clear
win for white so yeah make sure to
always think about which one is the more
forced and the most clear way to win all
right so now the question is why does
gathered many pieces around the enemy
team
how can you conclude the attack now so
well to answer Anna after rugby one
night if to kingi - you're still holding
okay so in this position I still don't
really have suggestions is this capable
uncle's game um no unfortunately they I
wish it was but most of this game has
happened in 2002
okay so I'm getting suggestions of
Brooke the 896 check and Knight takes g7
or Bishop 67 so I would recommend to
first think about the check for example
the 97 96 1 so if you know for sure that
that doesn't work then okay think about
other moves such as rip d8 okay so I'm
getting a Bishop g7 and then rook c8
sorry let's see
yep so 97 actually is a bad move because
the problem with 97 is it's wrong
because what if you take wait hold on
I'm I don't speak German and I have
German explanations here so we Amy
oh the problem is that at the end of the
line you're not gonna have tonight h6
check C in Bishop g7 after takeoff d8
night to try and protect you have this
awesome night h6 but with 97 you got the
end of the line you won't have that
night h6 so yeah
[Music]
this was pretty beautiful one thing I
think I went a little too fast over here
after you create for those of you who
found Knights 6 congratulation it is not
easy to find and for those of you who
found Queen H Queen takes g7 another set
of congratulations Bravo and alright so
this one actually was pretty pretty kind
of pretty
I will definitely show it to some of my
friends too
okay so basically clear the question is
do you see who the winning stripe or
white
okay I'm getting suggestions of rooks
like p7 check so preferably give me a
fool on my group takes p7 what if King
takes p7 so II 7 is another move that
you should definitely think about
because II 7 you're gonna make a queen
and if Bishop takes Bishop Wien g7 and
you are super winning
so yeah just rook d7 King miserably one
King Caesar and Queen B 8 okay cool yeah
I honestly think a 7 also could work but
let's see
yep work visa the idea is very simple
you take check and mates like this even
if you were to see seven instead of King
e6 Queen b8 as mentioned in the chat so
yeah very well done this one is black to
move and try to find the winning move
please
all right so I'm getting ideas of Queen
taste G to check if Bishop g2 then rook
d1 I like it
well what do you think happens after
root D 1 because if rook T 1 there are
some moves that you should think about
one of them should be Bishop e won't
check because they shall be want to stop
the check and open like an airway for
King then another one is king h2 but
after King is to Knight g4 kind of
finishes the game off right
so yeah just make sure you think about
all of these before
arts
so
it is a little bit easier to think about
your t1 first and the idea is kind of
simple if you take it your mate if you
don't take it and play Bishop e1 I just
take it and I just I just want a piece
so I'm just gonna hang around and just
enjoy my extra piece and if you were to
play king h2 now this idea of queen g2
works cuz after clean g2 you get 94
mates so for those of you who suggested
Queen g2 first you have the right idea
but the wrong move order because
preferably you would want to have the
chance to keep as many as pieces as
possible so instead of giving up your
queen you would try to give up your
[ __ ] your rook first so make sense
first no should be rook d1
so
basically black last move was whoops
kind of careless so white wants to try
and take advantage of it and yeah the
first thing I think you should think
about is what are the checks possible
and what are the weaknesses in the
position because if there are too many
weaknesses then you can try to start
exploiting them
okay so I'm getting suggestions such as
Knight g4 and Bishop h6 so I personally
like 94 a little bit more just because
it's kind of tempting and you are
attacking your opponent's night and
night can't take it and now you might
have ideas and I've see especially six
and there's no real good way for black
to defend it the one thing that you
should definitely think about is after
Knight g4 if there is 94 or Bishop b4
possible well we should be for is not
possible because my takes up 6 check and
then you just take on e4
94 is a very good move if you take its
mate if you move the rook
it's very nice personal very nice
positional advantage and mate should be
coming up very soon
so in this position please take a second
well okay 30 seconds and tell me their
bright move the finishing move please
think about checks first and then takes
and you shouldn't have to go farther
than checks and takes
well
honestly I think any of the moves that
you're suggesting is going to win but
it's not the most accurate or the most
beautiful one
so I mean d5 is a good move Bishop takes
this is a good move
yes rookie six is the move that I was
looking for so it's the shortest way to
win because I have to take just check
and Bishop g6 and yep that's just get it
done so now it's white you move again
and the question is kind of funny the
question is blacks last move looks
reasonable but in fact it's a very bad
sleep how to punish black boards and
just should be clear the last move that
black did was night to take the Knights
from f5 to e7 the best move wants to
play Queen d7
okay nice I'm getting good suggestions
with queenís five and nine three five
and Bishop h7 so these should be the
moves that you are thinking about but
preferably give me a full line okay
I just got a full line this other
southern kh7 queen is five
kingi 895 yeah I think that should be
the most logical way to handle it
yep after take queen is five like try
not to do Knight g5 first cuz you give
your opponent the chance to play king g6
yeah and then it just makes things more
complicated and just trying them one of
the most important lessons that I've
learned playing chess is to never ever
give your opponent's the chance to try
and slip away and sometimes it's like a
such a basic rule but we miss it and we
think oh this is also winning and yeah
so try to work on yourself to play the
most and knowing in most forcing moves
so yeah for example Queen s5 is the best
one kingi 895 so so far everything is
forced
basically the only thing that you would
have to decide on is giving this check
and taking the queen
and after that well it's still a little
you still have to be very careful
because you don't want to give your
opponent chance to run away so that's
why you would have to play Bishop h6
most forcing moves and to give this
check and just be able to get the piece
basically all right next one
so all the white pieces are very active
how are you going to use it
while you guys are thinking if you have
any other questions about books openings
whatever whether anything ask it today
here in st. Louis the weather was
actually pretty nice a little humid but
I think it might start raining soon
because it was just way too humid not to
rain and yeah
okay so I'm getting suggestions of 95
and Queen g7 I like the boat honestly
but which one do you think is the more
forceful one which one do you think it's
kind of won't let black slip away
not c4 is another nice idea
okay so
[Music]
9f5 is the best one simply because it's
kind of the most forceful one and it's
giving tonight is really just the reason
that you're gonna win this game because
if you take it the problem is that now
you get Queen g7 as a lot of you
suggested and now after rue kf8 you
simply just take on f6 and the only way
that's black and try to delay mates is
with queen a tree
now take is minutes and find me the best
move on how you're gonna win this game
cuz this is pretty pretty winning just
you need to have one final move please
well rookie 7 I mean a lot of these
moves are winning but it's not the most
accurate one the most accurate one is
Rick t6 you are simply kind of
suffocating the king and next one you
were just taking Queen East 7 I do think
her k5 is also should work because Ricky
file is also trying to take the Queen
and you your queen can't really stay
anywhere to defend this Soto k5 is
another nice move thank you for
suggesting it alright let's do another
one
so basically let's black to move how can
you win
so just to give you a little bit of tips
black or whites last one was bringing a
queen to be one which is well under the
bet the best moment was to play C for
here C for if the rook takes just to
exchange everything and go to an endgame
that is kind of um kind of hard to win
last Queen B 5oz plates so not always
black soon
so yes I am getting good suggestions of
Knight c3 and I think that's the that's
the move that should do it
another good move is ninth beat you so
the thing is glued Knight c3 you were
kind of giving White's room to draw to
get away because white can't have to
take it you take it and this is a very
strong attack but it might not be enough
because let's say just King a1 what are
you gonna do fruit b6 let's say Queen a
for its kind of still holding on and I
do believe that it should be good good
enough attack but it's a little you have
a more accurate way so nice b2 is that
accurate way and after let's say rook b2
you just take c3 and you just win the
Queen if the King takes you just take c3
with the rook if rook takes you just
take what the Queen and this is kind of
just winning on spot and another thing
to think about is if rook just goes away
to teach you and again you have the same
idea of rook C to check and Roxy one and
just meet so yeah this was a very nice
one because my c3 is the move that you
would keep thinking about and IC 3 is
with check it's taking its opening step
up but Knight beat you is the most
accurate one I think it's mainly because
it's bringing the king out and you're
kind of getting that extra Tempe to be
able to take it back with the drug
without why it's being able to take back
with the rook so yeah
this one is white to move and what's
gonna win
so maybe tell me how how do I prepare
opening up her tours well usually when
I'm watching the game I see what I like
and what I don't like about it and if I
really like the way that the position
turns out if it feels like it's my style
I try to look more games on it and then
look it up with Andrea and see if I have
anything already analyzed and I just
start going from there
what is my style I really like the
positions that kind of helps you have
too much space and then you end up
having a lot of positional and tactical
chances so I really like those so yeah
let's see we have suggestions of Bishop
g7 and a lot of Bishop g7 and Queen g5
so I don't think when g5 is the most
accurate just because White's black will
have a bunch of checks so let's see I
kind of like Bishop g7 more mainly
because Bishop g7 this sacrifice is very
interesting because you have to take it
and then you get g8 Queen I also think
route g5 is winning mainly because if
you play King of shades I just have rook
g8 and the other one to h1 and just
check and this is mate and the problem
is you have this to with move the rook
g1 and rook and King h8 sorry making a
queen on a shades so let's say you make
the Queen tank check and you just take
the Queen back this should be good
enough to so if you're actually winning
your queen on the game that's enough you
don't really necessarily have to look
for that crazy mates just the one thing
that you have to be careful is not to
take the night over here because that
would give your opponent a chance to
actually try and save the game by taking
check you have to play King a1 not Roxy
- now if you do Bishop g7 which is the
most logical move I have to take you
make a queen it's still nice try but
it's very dangerous
it's not worth it so honestly it might
be a little hard to calculates from here
to here but from here you can definitely
calculate up until Roxy - and when you
see Roxy - you should to look for
another line unless this is the only
line then yeah okay you have to
calculate this but if you see Roxy - you
kind of have to stop here because now
there's this made threats and it's you
don't want that you don't want your plan
to have different made threats in one so
okay let's do the one last one and this
one is also white stick move and the
first thing that you see in this
position should be how weak the black
king is and that the fact that you've
already given up a rook so that should
give you the idea that you should keep
checking and sacrificing this Queen on
c3 is looking very nicely on the 88
square right
time control I really like I used to
like a lots that when the time control
was like 20 minutes like five seconds
something like that just because I
wanted to have the time to actually
think online but right now I prefer more
rapid games more like ten to five - I'm
not the biggest fan of three - I guess
it just feels like it's getting too
close - just making moves and flagging
the opponent okay so I'm getting ideas
of okay change 94 97 all of them are
pretty good so I think the first thing
you should think about is the checks or
Turkish aids and then when you start
thinking about your kitchen 8 you
immediately well black only has two
moves King takes a Shaytan King g7 first
of all if King takes a shades you give
this double check and take the Queen and
the position for black is pretty
hopeless so the only other option for
black to think about this playing King
g7 which also gives up the rook and now
you have the threat of queen is tree and
then Queen is 8 so let's say black tries
to play Queen d4 in this position you
can simply just exchange the Queen's and
go for eating material which is
perfectly fine another thing that I was
just thinking about that I found kind of
interesting was the idea of maybe 96 or
97 because if you take I'm just gonna
take your rook and if you you just you
can't really hold this night if you play
like Bishop b5 I just take this night so
I thought that's interesting to you but
I think in the game they play jerky 7
and went for the f7 calm
and this is still very pleasant position
very putting too much pressure
a lot of winnings ideas yep it is a good
idea to always calculate the cheques
captures and attacks so yeah that is all
I have for today right now I hope you
guys enjoyed it and this is a fun tactic
a lot of fun tactics if you have time
and if you didn't watch the end game
that we did an hour ago go watch that
that was kind of fun too yeah well until
next time stay safe wash your hands
we're pretty colors if it makes you
happy oh let me figure out how to end oh
I see the red button all right there